I have a brother-in-law who is being
completely enabled by my mother-in-law
and father-in-law he is currently still
living at home he's almost 40 years old
and he has some uh he has a drug
addiction problem as well as he's
currently not working we've recently
purchased a house and it has a complete
separate in-law suite their eyes kind of
got a little bit big when they saw the
new house that we purchased for
ourselves kind of hinting at the fact
that potentially um the brother could
potentially move in with us how do I
plight
explain to them I have zero desire of
him moving into a house you don't your
husband does it's his mother not
yours absolutely I agree with you um
your husband have a backbone or does he
need to run down to Walmart and pick one
up I think I need to buy him one for
Christmas no okay I'll three I'll three
at Walmart